what's that you say there's so many
games on game pass you don't know where
to begin well lucky for you we have a
list of 11 games that shouldn't go
missed on game pass hopefully you'll get
a glimpse into the next game you'll want
to check out that you may have not known
about otherwise so let's get this thing
going
first we have telling lies an
investigative thriller mystery where you
dig through video files and
conversations to piece together the
truth surrounding a shocking incident
that involves the lives of four people
the great thing about telling lies is
that it's completely non-linear and how
you search and pry information is
entirely up to your own deductive skills
it's done entirely through an in-game
database where you can type search terms
and specific phrases spoken in the video
clips it's an incredibly gripping and
intimate concept that places all the
evidence in front of you right from the
start but it's up to you and how far you
want to dig to solve the mystery telling
lies is from developer sam barlow who
also gave us her story unfortunately her
story isn't on game pass which is a
shame because i think it's great but who
knows maybe you'll play this and be like
damn now i gotta play her story because
kurt from gamespot was like is really
good and stuff
madden nfl 22 bet you never heard of
this game before as long as you have ea
play which is included with a game pass
ultimate subscription you get the big ol
football game this edition and the
yearly release of madden nfl games you
get a bunch of redeveloped franchise
features so you can live out your
impassioned fantasy to find the next
star talent in the country they've also
worked managing staff as well and
leveling up your coach crew madden nfl
22 is also the introduction to game day
momentum a meter that affects the
performance of each team based on
intensity of fans in the audience
now if you have ea play this isn't the
only man in game available but it's the
latest so why not get in there and
reenact your fantasy super bowl thing
with the
touchdowns and teams you like that
didn't make it this time
go bills
and the raiders
who both didn't make it
here's a new one for you dreamscaper
it's a game where reality and dreaming
collide in a really refreshing and cool
gameplay cycle spend your days exploring
the city of red haven meeting people and
building relationships and when you fall
asleep at night you're holed into an
ever-changing nightmarish landscape
where you must fight monsters lingering
in your subconscious depending how you
spend your days and the relationships
you build can unlock permanent upgrades
to take with you into your nightmares
and fend off foes
and in the process unfold the memories
and experiences of its protagonist
cassidy there's plenty of approaches to
combat and different abilities to obtain
and loads of weapons including a yo-yo
so dream die wake repeat which is the
exact wording i'd like on my tombstone
this one has been my go-to during the
morning coffee the pedestrian it's a 2.5
d side-scrolling puzzle platformer you
control pedestrian illustration that
reverses flat surfaces like signs
screens paper and other stuff but in a
lively 3d world the puzzles are no joke
either you'll be shifting around signs
interconnecting other flat surfaces
together and learning new rules around
every quarter in order to push forward
with each environment featuring its own
unique direction and design it's been a
really engaging and easy pickup game to
start my weekend mornings with so when
you're not going in and out of
nightmares or solving a mystery and
telling lies the pedestrians spin a good
change of pace
echo generation it's a turn-based
adventure set in the 90s oozing with
nostalgia and child-like wonder mystery
engulfs a small town after crash leads
to some spooky outcomes not only is the
voxel art style a refreshing twist but
this game is packed with loads of whimsy
characters monsters ghouls and
imagination additionally its active
turn-based combat requires the player's
attention to time things just right it's
all about supernatural family and
nostalgia with this one and is packed
with a conspiracy that transcends time
itself
[Music]
now i've seen this one pop up in the
comments a couple times so i figured i
toss it in neon abyss it's a panic
struck roguelike action platformer
that'll have you running and gunning
your way into the abyss you're a member
of the grim squad a task force initiated
by hades to dive into the abyss and take
down the new gods thing is death is not
entirely defeat as every time you die
you'll find yourself more powerful in
classic roguelike fashion each run is
unique with new rooms items bosses and
multiple endings and thankfully the
abyss doesn't have to be so lonely
because you get to hatch and evolve pets
that'll fight alongside you each with
their own distinct abilities
there just doesn't seem to be enough
roguelikes these days and if you're in a
rogulex well then this is the list for
you because here's another one skull the
hero slayer it's a fast paced action
roguelike that'll have you playing as 90
different playable characters with their
own abilities and items since you're a
skeleton you gain attributes and powers
by wearing the skulls of other
characters granting you their special
powers and skills it's rambunctious in
its combat and style and is loaded with
white knuckle action and tons of variety
and charm
wait what's that another roguelite you
say why of course into the pit is a
fast-paced retro-style first-person
shooter that packs the same intensity as
something like hexen in a fantastical
bullet hell kind of way after a demonic
pit is discovered in a small village
you're thrusted in the depths using an
ever-changing array of abilities and
magic to blast through demons and
monsters of all shapes and sizes coming
at you on all surrounding sides
into the pit is teeth grinding at times
and can be pretty difficult but hurling
dark magic from your fingertips like you
were firing off guns can be a lot of
addictive fun
alright enough of the roguelikes now for
something completely different like lost
words beyond the page it's a puzzle
adventure game where you explore the
vibrant pages of a young girl's diary
navigating the words and world by
jumping through the pages and using the
words themselves as tools to solve
puzzles in a really unique and beautiful
way the story in which unravels are the
words and memories you'll be physically
walking and jumping up which is a really
clever way of intertwining story
development as a literal means of
gameplay some might say that the story
jumps off the page
next on our list is the dystopian
pseudo-management sim mind scanners it's
a retro futuristic sim where you have to
locate and diagnose citizens from an
anti-utopia metropolis and normalize
them this could entail implanting
citizens with certain chips or even
erasing parts of their memory in order
to make them perfectly functionable and
indistinct individuals in this dystopian
world the process is done in a sort of
arcadey way using minigames to execute
your diagnosis conceptually the game is
very very bleak but is handled in a
satirical and charming fashion but
ultimately there's more to its dark
themes than meets the eye
[Music]
ah yes the drum master classic this
rhythm game is all about drumming out to
over 70 songs alone or with friends
maybe even sometimes against them the
best part is how incredibly approachable
this game is as it only involves two
notes the don and ka don't be fooled
though you can ramp up the intensity if
you want a challenge or just to jam out
to a different beat the music selection
is also quite broad ranging from anime
to classical to pop and beyond
alright game passers that's all we got
for today these videos come out in
monthly installments so if a game you
love on game pass wasn't on this list
drop it in the comments after all
there's a chance it may have been in a
previous video and if not i'll make sure
to add it to the next one alright folks
keep playing games and enjoy what you
enjoy till next time see you later
[Music]